[Music]
fear to me means absolutely nothing
anymore fear played such a big piece of
my life and it controlled me to not do
what was best for me so fear to me now
is nothing but an imagination
[Music]
my name is flip Rodriguez I'm a
Hollywood stuntman and on American Ninja
Warrior in the ages of 9 to 15 I was
sexually abused by my father like how do
I live my life after that like I can't
trust anybody I got into parkour and
freerunning when I was the age of 19
Park one for you running are two
different definitions are very similar
parkour is just straight forward
vaulting jumping over walls over any
obstacle in your way rerunning is your
own style your own flippin flow of it
make it nice and pretty as possible and
you take your time when I first got
started I've never been upside down so
my body's like wait whoa we don't do
that and then the fear aspect hits in so
it's like let's stop and think about
this is this really worth getting hurt
[Music]
fear is what stopped me from trying to
stop my sexual abuse parkour and
freerunning has been a stepping stone
for me to heal and be okay with my
sexual abuse it's because fear is a big
part of parkour and freerunning so every
day I trained I was always encountering
a new fear
I started in American Ninja Warrior
season 3 and then on season 7 actually
explained my story I was sexually abused
after my interview came out I've had
kids write to me one of the parents
reached out to me turns out that the
daughter and the son were being sexually
abused by a family friend the child just
started breaking down crying
she was like what flip is talking about
is also happy to me and they brought up
charges the gentleman got convicted of
that and that right there blew my mind
away because not only did I heal myself
but I also saved somebody from further
abuse and that was incredible I like to
give back to the community with using my
story I coach Parkman free running I'm
not teaching him just about parkour free
running I try to teach them tools of
life you guys just saw me kind of fell a
little bit what do you got to say
every single person can relate to fear
yeah
so if I can teach these kids from a
young age to separate fear from danger
that is a life tool my negative piece of
my life I can now turn it around and put
a spotlight on it in the sense of this
is who I am this is what happens to me
and look at me I'm still shining people
have told me I have saved their life I
[Music]
became an excellent artist organ -
because I deal with my own pain each day
ASMR has truly helped me focus on living
instead of dying
I asked my artist is someone who focused
mainly on visual triggers and sounds to
bring you some type of relaxation some
of the misconceptions that people have
with ASMR is thinking that is creepy
this Prezi is weird and I believe the
reason why some people believe that is
more so we're discussing I'm constantly
whispering but when is noises whisper is
to bring you to that safe place it's to
make you feel calm
I find myself in any and everything that
I do if I'm opening up a pack of gum if
I'm brushing my hair
people love for it sounds like the
people video I don't know what happens
why does eating a pickle causes a person
bring to shut down but it will I have a
degenerative bone disease I can't stop
it there's no cure before I discover is
I'm or I could not move I didn't have
the strength to make myself stand up so
when I discovered SMR I felt extremely
relaxed I feel like I was actually
smiling just laying there I felt really
really good mentally more so than being
on medication
and I said okay I'm gonna create a
channel and I'm gonna create more videos
because there's a lot of people who are
dealing with stress insomnia anxiety we
just need some comfort to get them
through the night I receive email from
people who are bedridden and let me know
how much I have helped them I always
told my children one person could have
changed the world and to actually be a
part of maybe some type of change and
some type of way is amazing there's
something about being part of nature
there's something about being around
these animals even the most wounded
veteran they feel different keeps them
part of something greater than
themselves
[Music]
the idea is that you've got to give
someone who's been through a severe
trauma an opportunity to heal and we
believe it
Warriors and wolves program and a back
to nature setting it does that we have
40 animals
at this facility we've rescued wolves
off of chains in Alaska as part of a
roadside attraction we rescued wolf dogs
from a backyard breeder in San Diego I
think for all the veterans that we bring
out here whether they work here or
they're here for a support group
what rings true is if they can heal I
can do the Wolves the nullus you're
injured or something's wrong with you
and they have that trauma so I you know
we had some type of trauma on life we
can't get that connection and one wolf
would be your friend for life what
happens is one animal picks that one
veteran never again does that animal
pick someone else never again does that
animal want to show the same kind of
affection to someone else boy
conventional therapy isn't really
something for me didn't help to be
honest after 10 years of military life
it was sort of a tough transition and I
continued down my course of being angry
drinking myself to death may have been
last chapter of my life
[Music]
there are things I've seen that I can't
unsee there are things I've done that I
cannot undo just saying that well I did
it in the name of my country doesn't
help you sleep at night but what does
help you sleep is having a companion
they kind of teach you how to be calm
and confident it's it's got some deeper
meaning when they accept you they accept
you into the family part of the pack
[Music]
laughter is like a spiritual practice
for me Allah everywhere I go what I
believe that world can be a better place
with more and more people start laughing
[Music]
my name is madame Kataria I'm a medical
doctor and creator of laughter yoga this
time laughter yoga is a unique concept
where anyone can laugh for no reason at
all we don't need to rely on jokes sense
of humor or comedies laughter and whines
the negative effects of stress and makes
our immune system stronger and brings
more oxygen to our body and brain the
reason we call it laughter yo guys it's
a combination of laughter exercising
with deburring techniques from yoga
scientifically our body doesn't know the
difference between real laughter and
fake laughter we still get the same
health benefits
I created laughter yoga because my life
was very stressful being editor of a
health magazine and medical
practitioners I could not find any
relief from the stress then I found a
breakthrough that there is a lot of
medicine in laughter based on this idea
I created laughed as a form of exercise
I wake up at 4:00 in the morning and the
first thing I do is allow for 30 40
minutes every day I'm laughing in my
daily routine laughing with my staff
everybody calls me nobody sees me and
laughing on skype
I'm teaching laughter yoga one day I'm
going to die laughing my mission in life
is to create social after clubs which
are free for everyone in the world when
we laugh in a group it becomes real and
contagious it becomes easier to laugh
now we have more than 16-thousand
laughter clubs in 100 countries when you
find happiness with will with laughter
practice the perception of the audience
we can create happiness within ourselves
[Music]